depuis l'âge de 3 ans megan fortin voue
une véritable passion pour la peinture
abstraite dans mes toiles gêne que ça
soit équilibré desquelles beaucoup de
couleurs 6e aussi que ça soit épuré qui
naît avec les couleurs souvent des
couleurs mois et représente une
dimension va demeure quand même un
loisir une passion et médiane et est
étudiante à lui pris une ampleur plus
grande qu'on aurait imaginé au départ
megan fortin est membre d'un
regroupement international d'artistes
appui à mme dont le but est de
promouvoir leur travail à l'étranger
la jeune artiste de 10 ans a déjà
quarante cinq toiles de vendu que des
collectionneurs d'europe qui ont
commencé à acheter des toiles mégane est
une en famille à mon sens et des jeux
une artiste à part entière
elle a été reconnue par les artistes
professionnels auxquels plein jack se
sont mobilisés autour de megan pour lui
ouvrir une carrière à l'international
l'artiste peintre marie josée lépine et
le professeur de ligue 1 selon elle
l'enfant a trouvé sa propre signature
saison de travailler au sol est bon à la
fois travailler avec des mouvements
accents très ample et elle est capable
de travailler ou fait dans le mouvement
qui est retenue qui est calculée cave à
savoir exactement qu'est ce qu'elle a
envie d'ajouter à l'intérieur de sa
toile
donc ça fait un résultat qui est colorée
qui est vif et qui est qu'ils puissent
je peux tourner autour de la toile puis
je peux faire des grands des plus grands
gestes que temps je suis à 6 1 permet de
m'exprimer mais garde tient sa première
exposition solo à la bibliothèque de
stoneham dans la suite une partie de sa
collection ira los angeles
il ya une partie qui fait explosé il ya
une partie qui va être achetée en fait
une firme d'architectes qui attendent
pour au niveau des collectionneurs on
s'en va pour le marché américain le
vraiment pour on espère de l'ong
revenaient vraiment content
parce que je sais que pour beaucoup de
gens mon âge qui forment des toiles
abstraites comme celui qu'ils vont avoir
la chance que l'étoile iea le centre du
caire dd je trouve que je suis vraiment
changé il si nicole jamet radio canada
québec